there are certain areas exotic cars down  collectible cards down nfts down nearly  94  you can go through so many of these  things that people just kind of throwing  money at it yeah you want to go on a  vacation let's go get an Airbnb yeah you  want to go let's go buy a collectible  card the same Kobe Bryant card that's  one of two that sold for 1.7 million  dollars  two years ago I want to say sold for 690  000 two months ago okay there's only two  of those cards it's his best card in the  world only sold for six six ninety  roughly 700 000 this card got a 1.7  million dollars a year and a half ago in  the last 12 18 months same exact card  same again you know how we say VIN  number same exact identification  everything's the same so for more than  50 why  why are people not doing it I don't know  maybe people are hoping they keep their  cash because they're going to need it  for other places